do you need to find a little more calm
in your busy life leave some stress and
help quiet your worries well we have a
segment to help you that's right it's
time for good and five
and today we're talking mindfulness and
joining us is someone i've known for
more than a decade oh well more than
like at least 15 years i think so she is
a holistic wellness expert and a new
york times best-selling author a very
prolific writer by the way how many
books do you have now this is my sixth
one
please welcome kimberly snyder
you started in nutrition
but with this book um and the ones
you've written with deepak chopra
you are going and connecting the mindful
connection to it so
for those who don't know what
mindfulness is i think we all know it
but what is it to you explain through
your eyes what you mean when you say
mindfulness yes so first of all when we
want to get the best results we want to
feel the best in our life we need to
nourish ourselves not just with food our
physical body but also emotionally
mentally and spiritually when we nourish
our whole self that's when we become our
most powerful our most clear and we come
from this deeper more intuitive place
mindfulness is really the tools and
strategies for coming into this moment
fully present so it's giving us the
chance to break free of all the fear and
the mind chatter that's always running
around and coming right here and now so
we can come into this moment with
clarity with our um again just our
intuition and everything tends to flow
more in our life we open up more and we
create more healthy relationships so
when we're mindful we have the ability
to soothe ourselves to shift our energy
to nourish ourselves so we're not
projecting our stress our emotional
needs our mental needs outward whether
it's to food that's why you know food
cravings keep coming back around and
again we struggle with weight or
unhealthy friendships or whatever it is
out here we realize we have the power to
really rise up to each moment and it's
something that's easy to do all right
well i like that because it's like you
know your life is going on how do you
get centered rather than completely a
life overhaul which most people are like
i can't do that yes so you're working
from the inside out
[Music]